there's a lot to learn with making
background transactions efficient but
the good news is that Android gives you
the Sync manager framework that
implements many of these best practices
you utilize that framework by
implementing a sync adapter the
framework originally introduced in
Android 2.0 Eclair or Android API level
5 allows Android applications to
leverage the same basic framework that
Google Apps use for efficiency
organization ultimately it's a
centralized place to put all of the
device data transfers in one place so
that they all be scheduled intelligently
by the OS in other words that's one big
cookie Android sync manager handles
synchronization requests using sync
adapters the sync manager batches and
time shifts these requests when possible
to allow your data transfers to be
scheduled with transfers from other apps
all working towards the goal of reducing
the number of times the system has to
switch on the radio if your device has
less memory it will schedule fewer
simultaneous syncs the sync manager also
takes care of things like checking for
network connectivity before initiating
transfers and retrying downloads when
connectivity is dropped the
synchronization framework works with
content providers for two-way
synchronization and leverages the
Android Account Manager to provide
synchronization services that are tied
to accounts our application will do
neither of these things but we'll still
have to deal with some of the complexity
of these features this can make sync
adapter seem daunting at first what does
the sync manager do to help you fetch
data from the network does it schedule
your network jobs with other apps
implement a synchronization protocol
store account information or has logic
to retry a request select all of these
that match